[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Welcome to Google
I/O, and welcome to Shoreline.
We live in very,
very exciting times.
We, as Google, have evolved
significantly over the past 10
years, and we
believe we are poised
to take a big leap forward
in the next 10 years.
Today, we can do
things which we never
thought we could do before.
To do this well, we really
need to work with developers
and third parties,
but we believe
we are just getting started.
There are over 3 billion
people connected,
and they are using
the internet in ways
we have never seen before.
Learn new things.
Gain knowledge.
MALE SPEAKER:
Accessibility is crucially
important to Google's
mission, which, fundamentally,
is to make sure that
everyone around the world
can access the
world's information.
MALE SPEAKER: And I was just
fascinated with this idea
that we could bridge the gap
between our physical world
and our digital lives, that
we take our human nature
and embed it in technology.
MALE SPEAKER: And today,
we're proud to share,
with you, the new Firebase.
MALE SPEAKER: We're
adding more tools
to help you develop your app.
MALE SPEAKER: We're
really interested to hear
what you think,
and we can't wait
to see what you build next.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Ultimately,
it's up to all of us
to write the future of the web.
So go out there, and build a
great, progressive web app.
MALE SPEAKER:
Software developers
are changing our
world in a big way.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We're evolving
Android apps to run instantly,
without installation.
MALE SPEAKER: With
the end release,
we wanted to achieve a new
level of product excellence.
It's amazing to be
here at Google I/O 2016
at the Shoreline Amphitheater.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
I can't tell you
how much I've been
looking forward
to this moment for
a really long time.
MALE SPEAKER:
Communications is all
about sharing life's moments.
Communications is such an
important part of our lives,
and it's an important
focus for Google as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Our users and your
users expect the impossible.
They want technology that
they can talk to naturally,
just the way you would
talk to a person.
We're moving in that direction.
MALE SPEAKER: VR is about
what you can experience.
FEMALE SPEAKER: There's no
"once upon a time" anymore.
There's no "in a world."
You, as a visitor, are
now the storyteller.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Things
previously thought
to be impossible may,
in fact, be possible.
We look forward to building
the future together
with all of you.